[Musik]
hallo liebe
heute habe ich mir noch etwas ganz
besonderes überlegt dann wisst ihr was
ich bin so ein bisschen genervt davon
dass ich immer allein in der küche stehe
und ganz alleine backe und habe ich mir
gedacht hole ich mir doch mal ein
bisschen unterstützung und jetzt hab ich
hier niemand geringeres als den hallo du
vom büro sah ich freue mich hier zu sein
ich habe nicht da ist weil ich folge dir
ja schon mega mega langericht jörg genau
wie gegenseitig
jetzt hast du ja auch schon ganz viel
mitgebracht wo als junk food co hast
irgendwie immer süßigkeiten in der
tasche
das hat nicht so cool muss sein ich
danke auch wenn du natürlich auch mal
super leckere süßigkeiten und süße
sachen machen ich musste mal dass dies
ist ihr mitbringen aufnehmen kann ich
einfach zu dir kommen und dann einfach
gar nichts dabei bisher musste ich mir
sehr gut die flaschen auch gleich einen
job bat teile kommen auch auf die torte
wir haben uns für euch überlegt wir
machen heute einen candy cane also eine
schokoladentorte mit ganz viel
süßigkeiten oben drauf und ich glaube
wir starten jetzt einfach mal direkt und
es ist mein erstes mal in der küche
okay das ist ein kuchen bach zubereitet
ist okay das ist spannend auch gar nicht
zu hoffentlich machen wir bringen
nämlich ein anderer machen nichts kaputt
aber ich glaube china scheint in deiner
hilfe wird es bestimmt gedacht ich habe
also ich hab doch spaß dran ja geil so
daniel wir machen jetzt zuallererst eine
creme nach im natural ja das klingt
super chocolat und habe mir gedacht ich
stelle auch immer die zutaten mache ich
gerne ich meine es ist ja selten dass
ich mal produkte sehen die nicht
verarbeitet sind
eine zutat aber ich glaube das ist seine
schokoladen kuvertüre das sieht aus wie
frischkäse ja ich dich dann haben hier
puderzucker mascarpone und sahen ist 100
punkte
dank nicht das ist
naturtalent direkt also dahin jetzt
machen wir zuerst mal gar sagte das ja
schon davon gehört dass man ist ja auch
manchmal
damit ziehe die schokolade und da geben
wir jetzt heiße sein oder auf das heißt
einmal die sahne im topf erhitzen super
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich hab
noch nie was im topf erhitzt werde jetzt
gelogen aber ich habe noch gebacken
das stimmt wirklich deswegen bin ich
heute hier erhalten die gebacken und
habe gedacht
unter seiner aufsicht mache ich das auch
mal und wenn wir dann die fertig sind
dann seht ihr den langen nur noch
anpacken auf seinem kanal weiß die ich
findet man ja auch auf youtube noch ins
land sondern auf youtube und wonach
youtube instagram und meistens nur um
essen nicht erste sondern die kamera ist
hier das ist alles sehr kurzfristig da
bleibt für mich nicht mich lieben der
kamera ja du machst ja produkt für alle
die jetzt wieder an ihn nicht kennen
also ich kann es gar nicht vorstellen
weil ich gucke gerne videos auch
tatsächlich wenn ich mal aufräumen oder
entspanne ich ein tolles zu erzählen hat
also product reviews zu meistens ich
glaube aber auch in sachen da gibst du
punkte und richtet süßigkeiten und
snacks und ich gucke was gibt es am
schnellsten und immer die neuesten
produkte als erster sie haben deshalb
auch mittlerweile nette leute die mir
auf der neue produkte zu schicken wie
unterhalt immer so ein bisschen das neue
zu entdecken das ja ein antrat ja echt
spaß ja also jetzt nämlich auch hier
schon ein bisschen was mitgebracht ich
habe jetzt gerade so ingo schild fehlt
zum beispiel die hast du uns mitgebracht
richtig pralinen mit brownies olympia
vier punkte haben die von rebecca sagen
zehn punkte tatsächlich die volle
punktzahl schicken nur das erste würdig
mitgebracht war so sensationell gut
gelungen die haben auch mal pralinen mit
keks tag gemacht die von einige gut
andere nicht so genau aber die waren
einfach kompromisslos gut
ließ sich okay an dann muss ich davon
bis ein probieren und eine kommt auf
jeden fall auf unser klima was macht die
saale
was macht ihr denn gute frage ob sie die
umrühren hier muss man nichts um
die dampft ja schon wir sind gerade
anfing hochzusteigen kommt ganz einfach
über die schokolade
die nämlich darin genau und jetzt gebe
ich dann einfach nur ein teller drauf
leckere sage danke wir schneebesen ist
das glaube ich ja ich sage ich aus spaß
ich hab so was nicht zuhause leute okay
dann geben wir dir auf jeden fall ein
schritt soll dann hier ist schon
komplett in seinem element stößt gerade
die schoko sahne masse um sieht gut aus
ja wir haben wir haben ja die heiße
seien auch die schokolade gegossen und
eigentlich schmerz ist jetzt von einer
du musst also mit dem schneebesen ein
bisschen nachhelfen damit sich das
verbindet im anschluss nachdem das ganze
abkühlt schlagen wir das auch und dann
ist richtig richtig lecker mit den
anderen zutaten zusammen natürlich
er fliegt auch schon sehr lecker muss da
nicht ganz spannend und ich toll das
fühlt sich gut an
ja es fühlt sich wirklich gut an also
wenn ihr findet das er dann hier das gut
macht dann schreibt man das doch mal
eine kommentare das war doch nett das
wird mich sehr motiviert das ist nicht
drin zu bleiben ja in zukunft in bagdad
an nur noch theoretisch ja ich wollte
ihn dann ein bisschen ärger ist ganz gut
ich freue mich dass mit der hand so zu
beraten dass es sich einfach nur maximal
mache ich die mikrowellen tür auf zu
hause und backofen selbstgemachte finde
ich auch in überzahl das stimmt ist
glaube ich ja vor allen die hier ist er
selbst gemacht um eine andere liga ich
war selbst mache weiß ich nicht aber
hier ist es ja so wenig kunst dann
probieren wir nehmen's bereich und bin
ich ja mal gespannt auf das feedback sei
jetzt gebe ich dann nochmal den teller
drauf weil die sauna ist ja jetzt warm
und warm ist sich nicht so gut
aufschlagen daher müssen wir das ganze
ist kühl für ungefähr zweieinhalb
stunden im kühlschrank wir können ja
nicht zwischenzeiten käffchen trinken ja
noch ein bisschen zeit
ich habe ein bisschen zeit ich habe auch
eine süßigkeit dann sehen wir uns gleich
wieder ins abgekühlt ist jetzt
zweieinhalb stunden später zeit ging wie
im flug vorbei
ja das ist so ein bisschen lehrer und
nächsten schritt gehen jetzt das was du
gerade an gebühren
das hier einfach in die küche machen und
dann schlagen wir das auch in der sauna
fest dazu da bleibt das auch schon fest
und ich würde sagen jetzt zwischenzeit
menschen für die leckeren schoko kost
was machen wir gucken mich schon die
ganze zeit achten ob das ist echt eine
schöne masse gut aus kann man das schon
zu essen
ja da wird es aber ist schon sehr
verlockend kommen freut sich zuallererst
einmal ist ob das allererste mal sich so
ein ja tolles gerät bedienen daran jetzt
einmal volle power echt aber natürlich
mit kopien oder ja aber schließlich
jetzt fühlt sich richtig gut an
ob sie mich heute echt ein bisschen wie
meine erste mondlandung zu sehen ist das
cool das ist jetzt das endprodukt quasi
und das verarbeiten dann gleich weiter
ich muss im ausland ist nun nicht mehr
die nase stecken wir vielleicht nicht
mehr jeder danach spd also drin so ein
bisschen nasen aroma also wir gehen
jetzt als es die vier zutaten in die
schüssel möchtest du das gerne machen
würde ich gerne mal ausprobieren ich bin
ja auch heute hier weil ich ein bisschen
backen zubereiten lernen wollte ich hab
noch nie gemacht und ich habe das mal
gesagt im live video auf youtube
zusammen gekommen ja wir sind eigentlich
zusammengekommen also eigentlich
folgende und gegenseitig schon seit ich
weiß nicht zwei drei jahren also schon
lange auf jeden fall und dann hat der
daniel im livestream gesagt würdest dann
doch schon mal gerne was backen ja ist
auch mal mit kiki von klaren und das hat
mir dann eigentlich nur mit der er würde
wenn dann nur mit dir wirklich
gemeinsame zuschauer von uns beiden mir
zugeschickt und auch meine damen in
davos livestream und das habe ich
gemacht habe sagt daniel jeder zeit wann
immer du willst ja richtig cooler sind
sie zusammengekommen
[Musik]
das ist schon mal richtig gut aus also
als hättest du nie was anderes gemacht
oder ja bitte danke ich gut und ich gebe
jetzt hier die das was wir gerade eben
aufgeschlagen haben die schoko sahne die
habe ich jetzt hier noch mit unternehmen
und weiß was mich mal interessieren ob
daniel sieht toll aus was war das
ekligste an süßigkeiten was du je
probiert hast ich bin ja auch meister
darin so schlechte erfahrung zu
verdrängen die auszublenden
da müsste ich aber tatsächlich habe er
sich einst eingeprägt und jetzt war
tatsächlich einmal ahornsirup geschmack
nicht wollt ich mag also das vielleicht
weiß auch abgelaufen ich weiß nicht was
aaron maple und ganz musste ich
irgendwie hat ich hab dann hat gesagt
hat geschmeckt wie omas also so genau
als ich noch alben chips einen anstecker
an die haben ja auch mal gegessen fünf
toren die partie fand ich auch nicht
lecker eigentlich gedacht das
hafenbecken irgendwie so mundt hätte das
will ich nicht mehr
und dann kommen wir auch schon zum thema
der dann kommt nämlich aus hamburg ach
ja aus hamburg
also will dafür die die jetzt vielleicht
noch nicht wissen wo du herkommst mehr
hamburg und bochum dieser auch schon
längst erstreckt da stimmen aber umso
schöner dass es geklappt hat und wenn
ihr vielleicht noch mal möchte das was
du noch ein zweites mal kommen
vielleicht kochen wer dann mal war es
aber nicht aus der mikrowelle man hier
richtig so macht das ja tatsächlich
alles nur weil ich echt nicht kochen
kann ich habe hier schon 34 keine burger
verbraten worden ja aber du suchst
trotzdem immer wieder und hier habe ich
an minuten motivation das mit pizza oder
oder gehen oder etwas ähnliches auch ist
sie gerne
tausende stellen gerade auch zu einem
innenstadt oder cars rezept kommt auch
demnächst und deshalb mir geschmeckt und
ich es wirklich dreimal pro woche ist ja
super das muss man halt ja dann ja das
sagt ja du darfst probieren da nicht
jetzt sehr gespannt das sieht so toll
aus wir sind echt also ein bisschen wie
die kinder creme de la creme auf echten
kinder schokolade daher euch ehrlich
darf noch ein bisschen was wie es ein
ich würde es nicht noch besser machen
weil der geschmack ist so schön mit der
der mascarpone schmeckt schön frisch
cage frisch sättigend geil geil dass das
ist cool
denn dann bleibt alles so wie es ist
platz bleibt also wie hier ist und ich
hab den boden auch schon vorbereitet
weiterkommen das tue ich dem daniel
nicht an das sich noch im boden backen
muss ne und den habe ich da vorne
vorbereitet den schneiden wir jetzt
durch besser gesagt entscheidest du dich
ja nicht immer sehr gespannt die freude
ist riesig so wirklich das gebacken
meine frage ist es ja schon da waren
geschnitten ich habe so ein bisschen
angst aber passiert was kaputt machen
oder die platte cisco hat dank der kunst
ich auch sehr gut an der zeit hier und
ich damit schneiden kann kann jeder
damit schneiden ehrlich die tester ein
erster kuchen schnitt nur premieren
ehrlich toll sagt er gerade doch schon
das passende outfit anja holzfäller
dachte es ist wie so stöger
durch sie nochmal durch eine ball ist
klar insgesamt und die höhe kann ich so
was ist die beste wirkung
[Applaus]
das ist genial schön als hättest du nie
was anderes gemacht ja toll jetzt haben
mich einfach so hubl damit wir kriegen
einen auch nur noch mal von oben so ein
bisschen wegschneiden dann können wir
die rechte bahn
man ist ganz einfach ein tortenring
überholen und dann fühlen wir die creme
die wir gerade gemacht vor ein und
danach können wir alles drauf hat alles
was sie noch übrig ist dass wir gerade
in der pause nie angst haben vor so wir
bereiten alles vor uns gleich wieder so
jetzt haben wir hier dieses konstrukt
aufgebaut quasi so können wir das total
wie ein fön die creme und ich habe mir
das überlegen
ich habe doch gerade hier die herr
schäfer oben her grau und ich habe mir
ja diesen herrsche die robbe jetzt
nochmal ja die böden werden
ja das hört sich super an ist jetzt
sache der linken einer super kombination
das ist dank food group würdig
was übrig oder christian ich hab ein
bisschen was genau nicht einfach die
bühne mit trinken und dann wird das
ganze nur noch geschichte
und danach kann man schon erkannte sie
freien lauf es sieht schon so lecker
aussehen mit dem charakter und wenn du
willst kannst du das auch übernehmen
habe es noch benutzt einfach nur ich bin
nämlich mit dem pendel hast du so ein
gefühl der para halten und tränken trenk
denken aber nicht ertragen können und
auch nicht trinken
man kann jetzt schon drehen dann merke
ich gerade mein gott jetzt technik drin
und raffinesse lieblingswort backen
graffin essen kaufen
raffiniert kommt er ja super
ich will ein und du stress klappt super
mit diesem gerät mit diesem gerät der
gerät der geräte erstellt der gerät
schläft nie ins vollen chef im geschäft
der geregelte krieg schläft nicht
gedreht bevor die schriften sind immer
da man toll du musst das noch recht neue
werbegesicht werden dann ihren du machst
du das wär nicht toll wenn sie noch
kochen lernen und backen aber da bin ich
in der richtigen adresse eindruck machen
anderen haben sind es läuft so gut ich
habe angst dass ich nicht noch mal
verkaufen aber es sieht einfach gut aus
eine ebene wäre ja dann vielleicht gehe
ich vielleicht doch mal weiter an dem
profi das ist der grundbaustein steht ja
das ist jetzt alles das ist mir wichtig
also da jetzt auch dann in diesem video
ist es gibt bestimmte und irgendwelche
spielen wenn sie daniel sagt ja was war
eigentlich ist ein lecker stores säge
gästen ist und was du bist zum ende
seines lebens immer wieder essen kann
oh ja nicht entdeckt immer jede woche
etwas neues leckeres wohl total
ausflippen und aber wirklich das
allerletzte was mich schon seit längerer
zeit begeistert jetzt kommt es ist
natürlich ein produkt von der marke die
wir alle kennen ja ja genau
und dann noch eine marke von vier euro
kinder und es sind tatsächlich diese
kinder haselnuss 6 das ist eine kombi
aus kinderschokolade kinder bueno und
dann dieser form ja die kinder haase ho
6 dies tatsächlich auch an weihnachten
und ostern gibt hat denn immer so oft an
ihm vorbei haben ich habe die gehälter
echt geil ich mitbringen sollen habe ich
habe den crash course damit ich mal
vorbeikommen damit sich der mit seinen
grund gibt nun mal hier ein zu können
vielleicht habe ich gedacht ich schieße
das aroma der kinder ex händler gibt es
ja auch kaufland oder so naja könnte man
die eigentlichen ja müssen wir morgen
also ich kaufe eine gute adresse gratis
für ihre produkte
ja ja die haben da echte man ist ja
keine schlechte grad erneuerung da sie
ja jetzt kommt er die torte für ungefähr
eine halbe stunde in der küche kommt
dann haben sie auch noch ein bisschen
zeit zu naschen
heute zieht day ohne ende addiert
zusammen und dann sehen wir uns einfach
gleich wieder
jetzt ist die torte durch gekühlt und
machen das ist einfach einfach ok
einfach einfach wirklich gut aber nicht
dabei ihr habt ja gut das heißt ich
nehme jetzt einfach den tortenring ja
und dann haben wir einen eckball hast du
schon mal gehört dank kompakter kuchen
das heißt man sieht an die schichten
oder macht er keine creme nochmal
drumherum noch mal ganz wie sie es
gleich und ob ja wir brauchen wir nicht
einmal extra creme hole um die torte ich
mir deswegen würde ich mal sagen der
magische moment schlicht und schick
genau hier nicht und schickt einfach nur
noch einen schoko trip man sieht ihr so
schön die queen im unterricht cool oder
police geschnitten habe sieht ordentlich
aus hast hast du hast eine tolle vorlage
ja ja ich würde sagen sie haben doch
erst mal ein paar süßigkeiten aus dem
gleichen topf kommen dann mache ich sie
den trip und dann können wir alles
richtig schön der koreaner ja sehr gerne
am liebsten ja geil
du hast eine schöne auswahl hergebracht
ja dass wir eigentlich ist so lange her
die schokolade noch flüssig johann die
ganzen süßigkeit mal ein ton wie toll
dennoch fest werden lassen dann ist die
torte fertig unsere junk food co kennt
torte für nicht total genial die idee
ist ja auch so schick aus es findet ein
kunstwerk ja wir beide zusammen
beschreibt wirklich total gutes torten
kam heute mitgebracht kate kann richtig
gut dann lass uns mal aus nicht super im
formalen mit dem überraschungsei haben
wir für den spielspaß und schokolade
die attacke nicht einfach so da drauf
wie würdest du dir einfach in die mitte
nicht mehr umgedreht oder wie du willst
dass du bist so schön
ich hab da so ein ich glaube ich aber
ist der kontrast mag ich ja auch nun ja
ich mag den kontrast schön davon ist man
noch eine hälfte mit dazu ja das ist
wirklich ja und dann dann trocknet die
schokolade und dann hält auch alles
bomben supercoole sondern stones einfach
aus richtig
also legte sich doch nicht gut aus aber
wir müssen dennoch probieren wird heute
machen wir ja noch nie gegessen mit sehr
gespannt wie schmeckt es cookies in
krien wetzels geil schrie er wirklich
berät zwar richtig trainiert machte die
visagen gepäck genau ich habe jetzt mit
weißer schokolade und dem typischen
hershey kretschmann sensationell
[Musik]
können wir mal bitte darüber reden wie
geil diese tochter aussieht ich das
kenne ich sonst nur von instagram es ist
der wahr gewordene traum ehrlich
chocolat schokotraum ist instagram
fleißig posten daniel ich habe meine
waage ich glaube auch dass sich das
meine follower fragen wie bleibst du
schlank bei all den süßigkeiten
videotextes das ist tatsächlich die haut
am häufigsten gestellte frage muss ich
sagen das gute ist ich teste ja
süßigkeiten und ich teile immer auch die
western eine ganze tafel schokolade auf
seine ganze tüte chips sondern erhebt
das dann wieder zu und nehmen das damit
auf meine arbeit und teilt es mit
freunden und kollegen gibt also immer
süßigkeiten machbar die freundlich aber
bestimmt ein besonderes kollegen hätte
auch gerne das ist praktisch es gibt
jetzt ist mit dem hershey verlauf und
ich mir mit dem halter liegt oder dass
ried so lecker schon jetzt schon meine
gas einfach mal schokolade schokolade
traumhaft ich warte natürlich ist da
wirst du dein stück fällt mir schwer
weil er wirklich lecker ist mein stück
haben sie da kriegst natürlich gleich
auch ein schnell ich bin voll aufgeregt
ein trauma sieht so toll aussieht kann
nur schmecken der kann nur schwer so
dann wollen wir mal den test machen
wobei ich ihn richtig gut aber zuerst
ist sensationell wie lecker diese creme
hier mit dem dem teig auch harmonieren
na also nicht zu schwer oder man denkt
wenn man sich den kuchen an groupon muss
der schwer im magen so lange nicht
wirklich ja oder also ich finde auch das
schmeckt richtig klar hier und im frisch
durch den hirschen käse durch die maske
und jetzt die frage aller fragen wie
viele punkte 10 punkte unbedingt
nachmachen ja wirklich so ein mega cool
macht unbedingt nach ich gebe auch zehn
von plänen unbedingt nach münchen schaut
in die video beschreibung da stehen alle
genauen mengenangaben und auch dein
kanal beziehungsweise dann ins kanäle
sind dort verlinkt unbedingt
vorbeischauen und ein abo da lassen und
vor allem ich orientiere mich selber
immer dran bevor ich im supermarkt kaufe
hat der junk food oder schon getestet
und dann gucke nicht mehr eine bewertung
haben und wenn es in zehn von zehn sind
dann kauf ich mir auch wie kohl und
ansonsten ja wünschen wir euch viel
freude beim nachbacken und vielleicht
auf ein nächstes mal sehr gerne ich habe
so viel spaß gemacht auf jedoch da
hätten wir da ist ja auch schon was ich
will deinen kanal heißt ich heute
unbedingt abchecken und hier und dort
und deutlich nach oben da lassen und
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
mal will ich auch machen aber ist echt
toll
man hat das ganze stück fast gegessen
der ist echt lecker super geworden
wirklich keine zeit als lecker cremig
lecker
[Musik]